this is a video that I've made for
myself if anyone else gets any benefit
from it then that's an added bonus
speaking of added bonuses one of those
is available on nebula who have kindly
sponsored this video along with
curiositystream stick around to the end
to find out more about that as some of
you will know this was a very big year
for me and my partner we bought a house
together and then we got married which
uh cleared out our finances up until
this year we basically bummed whatever
savings we had into a savings account
knowing that we might need to use it at
any moment and that kind of precluded
any kind of investment strategy besides
that neither pixel or I knew what a
savings or investment strategy would
even look like well I've been a student
for eight years so post wedding Post
House I decided that I wanted to learn
how to invest properly and plan for the
financial future that came with a big
problem because as far as I could tell
if I wanted to get any kind of return
from an investment I either had to
invest in crypto or in a fund from some
big bank that supported for fuel
extraction or clubbing baby seals or
something money is unfortunately for now
what makes the world go round the way
that we use our money determines how the
world works and at the moment Financial
systems are geared towards activities
that harm the climate the amount of
money invested this way is responsible
for the situation we're in that means
though that changing how we use
Financial systems can be a powerful tool
to reshape the world if you're lucky
enough to have some money to invest then
you have a small measure of individual
power over which projects succeed and
which don't succeed in The Wider World
in other words where you put your money
matters so I had two objectives for
finding Investments and to be very clear
these are very modest Investments one
building on top of the other firstly not
doing any harm in other words not
picking any Investments that actively
make the problem of climate change worse
which basically translates into not
supporting any projects to do with
fossil fuel extraction and secondly
actually helping fix the problem in
other words picking Investments that are
actively trying to help climate
Solutions such as renewable energy
bringing down carbon emissions and
believe it or not Investments do exist
that meet these two criteria and they
can even give you a nice return so in
this video I'm going to share with you
what I learned on my journey and point
you towards some resources that might
help you weaponize your Investments to
combat the climate crisis but before
going any further my lawyer advises me
to make the following statement this
video is not Financial advice but it's
based on my own research and as I'm not
a financial advisor I am not authorized
to offer Financial advice always do your
own research and seek independent
Financial advice when required the valid
Investments can fall as well as rise
your Capital may be at risk okay so
before talking about which Investments
help the climate crisis we first need to
understand what kinds of Investments are
available to us now as I already said at
the start of my journey I was not an
expert at this so I asked one of my
friends who was alright so let's run
through what options we've got when it
comes to investing our money firstly we
have savings accounts this is basically
a bank account and you put the money in
it and you get usually a pretty small
rate of interest the good thing about a
savings account is you can take your
money out whenever you want the bad
thing about a savings account is that
your rate of interest is usually pretty
low next we have the whole broad
category of stocks and shares so this is
basically when you own a share in a
company like you might buy a share in
apple or something like that and you can
really do this in one of three ways you
could do it by picking individual stocks
for example by going on a broker's
website and buying a stock of Apple or
Tesla or whatever or alternatively you
can do it via funds now there's really
two types of funds that we want to be
aware of there's mutual funds and then
there's ETFs which stand for exchange
traded funds now a fund is basically
just a collection of stocks and shares
so for example a fund might have the top
20 tech companies that would be a fund
that has these 20 individual stocks a
mutual fund is a fund that is actively
managed I.E there is a fund manager who
is a physical person who's saying I
reckon we should invest in all these
different companies so it's a real
person doing the work whereas an ETF is
an exchange traded fund and this is a
pass fund so this might be for example
the S P 500 which is just a fund
containing all top 500 companies in the
US now in terms of pros and cons the
good thing about stocks and shares is
that you can generally get higher
returns compared to just interest
because the market overall goes up over
time but the problem is you could lose
some of your money especially if you're
investing in the short term like for
example if you'd invested your money in
stocks and shares just before the 2008
financial crisis you'd have been very
very negative for about two years before
the market took time to recover broadly
if you're considering between mutual
funds and ETFs most people would say go
for an ETF because they tend to have
lower fees as soon as you have an active
fund manager in a mutual fund suddenly
the fees go through the roof and it
becomes almost not worth doing category
number three that we might want to talk
about is Robo investing this is
basically where you put your money into
some kind of app where the app figures
out what kind of funds what kind of
stocks what what kind of stuff you want
to invest in and this can be good if you
want a very easy very user-friendly way
to invest your money but the downside is
that usually they have slightly higher
fees than if you just plain old invest
tested into an ETF a passively managed
exchange traded fund and then finally
category number four broadly is crypto
very speculative I would consider crypto
almost like gambling rather than
investing so this is our menu what we
now need to do is identify the
Investments within each of these
categories that meet our two objectives
for starters let's say that you want to
play Things extremely safe and put your
savings into a savings account
fortunately at least in the UK the law
says that retail Banking and Investment
Banking must be kept separate so any
money that you put into a High Street
Isa for example can't be used to finance
nefarious schemes or any positive
schemes for that matter however by
choosing a bank to open an account with
you are endorsing both the retail and
the investment side of their business
and many banks are still supporting
fossil fuel extraction in a big way
investment Charities share action
estimates that just since 2021 24 large
banks have supplied 33 billion dollars
in funding for new oil oil and gas
projects more than half of that total
amount came from just four Banks
Barclays HSBC BNP Paribas and Deutsche
Bank all of which are members of The Net
Zero banking Alliance hmm and it's not
just Banks let's say you wanted to
invest in a private pension well Friends
of the earth investigated the six
largest private pensions in the UK and
found that on average 4.3 Pence of every
pound invested in these pensions was
invested in fossil fuels that means the
average person with one of these
pensions has invested
1916 pounds each in actively making the
problem of climate change worse and I'm
gonna go on a limb here and say that
most people didn't want to do that so
what can you do instead well firstly
investigate what connections a potential
bank or pension fund has with fossil
fuels fortunately some people have
already done a lot of the legwork for
you a list of sustainable banks for each
country is available at bank.green I'll
leave links to all these in the
description by the way I was
unpleasantly surprised to learn that
that my bank Barclays was one of the
worst offenders in the UK so using this
list I'm investigating moving my current
accounts over to the cooperative bank or
Nationwide also I don't have one at the
moment but I would like to open a
private pension I obviously don't want
to invest in fossil fuels and I'm still
looking for the ideal fit here I haven't
found any good resources collating
options for this yet though one
potential option I've stumbled across is
the pension Operator by Circa 5000
previously ticker but let's say you'd
like a bigger return and you're willing
to accept a bit more risk and want to
invest in some stocks and shares well
that definitely makes it easier to avoid
doing harm
and allows your money to be more
proactive directly supporting an
organization and its actions the
financial return on an investment in a
stock or a share can obviously vary
wildly and it's entirely possible that
you will lose money doing this but by
picking particular Investments you can
be pretty confident that your money will
have a positive impact on the climate a
report earlier this year from the Boston
Consulting Group investigated which
Investments yielded the greatest
reductions in carbon emissions and found
that by far the best investment was in
alternatives to meat and dairy products
for each dollar investment in improving
and scaling up the production of meat
and dairy Alternatives resulted in three
times more greenhouse gas Productions
compared with investment in green cement
technology seven times more than green
buildings and eleven times more than
zero emission cars and there's still
huge potential for investment in this
sector the report noted that alternative
proteins sorry I I'm vegan and even I
think that sounds Grim have received a
fraction of the investment plowed into
other sectors like local carbon
construction I'm not going to recommend
specific shares or companies because I
think that would be irresponsible but
taking cues from this report it's pretty
clear that investing in specific sectors
can bring down carbon emissions and
maybe earn you some money personally I'm
not planning on investing in stocks or
shares because I'm quite risk-averse and
frankly I don't know what I'm doing so
as with the rest of this video if you
plan on investing in this way please do
your own research first or speak to a
financial professional something that
was much more appealing to me was the
returns of shares without having to pick
them myself so funds mutual funds and
ETFs looked very appealing generally
speaking in picking a fund the term
we're looking for is ESG ethical social
and governance investing there are
plenty of ESG funds out there by one
estimate a third of all funds are
managed according to ESG guidelines but
it's not as simple as just picking a
fund with the label ESG because the
other term we're looking for here is
green washing green washing is of course
the practice of making a thing appear
more environmentally friendly or less
environmentally damaging than it really
is for PR purposes a classic example is
luxury water brands like Fiji claiming
to be environmentally friendly while
still producing mountains of single-use
plastics and transporting water
thousands of miles from Fiji when uh you
don't need to do that while many funds
have the label ESG quite how
environmentally friendly they are varies
wildly something confounded by the fact
that there is no consistent methodology
for assessing what their climate impact
actually is or even agree on what ESG
means in my research I found that I had
to go on individual funds websites to
check what their criteria were for
making an investment and what their
portfolios were actually comprised of
and that's obviously not ideal for
trying to pick a fund so if you're
thinking of investing this way I have
two recommendations firstly
greenportfolio.com is an excellent
jumping off point for the start of your
research and once you've identified a
particular fund go to ishares.com and
look for the sustainability
characteristics section it will give you
lots of sort of Assessments on quite how
environmentally friendly that fund is
but secondly consider talking to a
financial expert that specializes in ESG
investing this is very complicated and
they are the experts again I'm not an
expert but in my personal research I
found some promising looking options
that you may want to consider as well
firstly here in the UK and I've actually
already mentioned them Circa 5000 is an
app that offers a passively managed
stocks and shares isop that explicitly
invests in low-carbon businesses and and
actively managed Alternatives there so
might even be better is the app climate
climate climate do note that both of
these apps are quite new and so there's
not much data to go on in terms of
predicting what kind of return you'll
get from them investing in any kind of
fund is obviously risky these ones
perhaps more so secondly I went through
quite a few ETFs and found that quite a
few of them just flat out didn't do what
they say they did like there was a clean
energy fund that had just two percent of
its portfolio in energy I'll put some of
the more promising ones up on screen
though obviously please do your own
research before touching any of these
fans and then lastly and this was really
cool to learn about Robo investing you
earned that 50 bucks you gave me a 20. I
did Robo investing is a specific kind of
fund that's exploded over the past
couple of years the way that it works is
you put deposits into the fund and it
automatically invests that money in a
diverse portfolio with you having
control over which assets get investment
in which sectors and how much risk you
want in the portfolio there are tons of
apps that offer this service and many of
those apps offer ESG options and
interestingly those ESG portfolios have
in some cases actually performed better
than the core portfolios that they offer
so you really don't have to sacrifice
your returns for your principles here
but unfortunately digging into the
details I couldn't find an app available
in the K that met both of my criteria
wealthify's ESG portfolio aims to limit
profits from producing Industries which
isn't good enough while nutmeg's ESG
portfolio explicitly doesn't invest in
polluting Industries but also doesn't
invest in anything that's actively
trying to lower carbon emissions if you
live in the US however an okay option
seems to be betterment's climate impact
portfolio though it will only invest a
small portion of your money into climate
Solutions as far as I could tell the
best option is a robo advisor called
carbon Collective which has a really
transparent framework entirely based
around lowering emissions and seems to
have a pretty good return too though as
Game of Thrones adequately demonstrated
past performance is no guarantee of
future results all right let's talk
through three General bits of advice
three top tips for investing which
people like Warren Buffett and all of
these like famous people who are
actually into investing would say number
one is that it's generally sensible to
have an emergency fund where you have
somewhere between three and six months
worth of living expenses so that if
anything bad were to happen you've at
least got this cash that you're not
going to touch for any reason other than
an emergency secondly if you are going
to invest it's worth probably investing
in stocks and shares but crucially you
want to probably avoid individual stock
picking this is a mistake that a lot of
people make and what Warren Buffett says
is that if he had basically any amount
of money to invest he would just put it
in an ETF an exchange traded fund like
the S P 500 this means that you're not
subject to the whims and ups and downs
of an individual company but you're
Diversified across the whole U.S stock
market if that's what you want to go
into and generally most people who lose
money in the stock market lose money
because they are trying to pick
individual stocks and one of those
stocks goes down to really low and then
that's obviously really bad and then tip
number three that I would say is that
however much money you have to invest
even if you're only investing five
pounds or ten pounds it's worth starting
sooner rather than later at the very
least it's worth just exploring who are
the online stock brokers in whatever
country you're in here in the UK
Vanguard and Hargreaves Lansdowne and
Charles Stanley direct are reasonable
options and it's worth just putting 5 or
10 pounds into the accounts and actually
just seeing what it's like to invest
your money in an individual stock or in
an exchange traded fund because what
that means is that when you start
actually getting serious about investing
maybe further down the line maybe you
get a raise at work and you want to put
more money in now you know how to do it
you've got the accounts you've verified
your identity all that stuff you don't
waste loads of time trying to get all
those things set up and I would know I
procrastinated for around three years
when I first started making money
because I kept on thinking authors
investing things seem you know I should
figure it out at some point but like the
timing never was never quite right and I
really wish someone had told me look man
just like put five pounds in an account
even if you don't have much money to
invest at least you know how it works
based on my research and the
recommendations of friends who know
better and might risk portfolio for now
I aim to move my current accounts away
from a bank that actively supports
fossil fuel extraction set up a pension
probably with Circa 5000 or an
equivalent I need to do a bit more
research here and then put a little bit
of money a month into an ETF or maybe an
app like climate if carbon Collective
ever comes to the UK okay I'm getting in
on that now throughout all this
discussion you may have had a question
what about crypto well especially with
recent developments I didn't want to
rush through crypto in this video and
instead do it as a separate Standalone
video about whether crypto is or could
ever be an eco-friendly investment and
that video is available right now over
on nebula who have kindly sponsored this
video it's the streaming service owned
and operated by a collection of
educational YouTubers including me where
we upload our content early without any
ads and alongside exclusive extra videos
like my videos on crypto dark matter and
Quantum field Theory and a huge number
of original series funded by our viewers
you see we love watching videos but we
hate watching ads so we run nebula on a
subscription model with some of your
money directly financing original
projects you can get a subscription at
curiositystream.com Simon Clark because
we are partnered with curiositystream if
nebula is the best of small scale create
is like myself and Wendover Productions
then curiosity's dream is the best of
big budget documentaries across every
subject imaginable with the likes of
David Attenborough and Hannah Frye out
of their thousands of titles you could
watch inside a Trader's brain a
documentary about neuro economics and
how Traders unconscious minds can have
disastrous effects on the global economy
signing up to curiosity stream and
nebula is possibly the best investment
you could ever make in your experience
watching educational entertaining videos
online and one of the best ways you can
support me as a Creator so I would
highly encourage you to check out
curiositystream.com Simon Clark and if
you do so as well as getting access to
curiosity stream and nebula you also get
access to a 26 discount so please do
check that out I would really appreciate
it as I appreciate curiosity stream and
nebula for sponsoring this video
as I said in the beginning this was a
video I made for me I wanted to learn
about this stuff and I figured that
there were probably quite a few of you
in my audience who would also like to
learn about it so I hope you took
something away even if not I did thanks
to my friend Ali for appearing in this
video If you're not familiar with him
here's one of his videos if you'd like
something else to watch from me next
here's one of mine and do check out
curiositystream and nebula down there
and you can also subscribe to this
channel that just leads me to say thank
you for watching I'll see you in the
next one